a little bit on these so I'm like oh how
you doing guys
we just finished the fourth prayer of
the day it's mug ative and I'm with our
brother how does cheated so I'm like oh
how you doing brother
I like somehow please be with you how
you doing fine fine I'm fine
my surname means I have to say one story
when I was in Australia my last fight
the ring speaker said my my surname
Harry's cool - can I stay and waiting
cool why he don't say my surname I don't
understand
later I figure out that it's my my
surname when the English tell us about
that because you're actually a world
champion kickboxer so that's the kind of
right he was fighting in the ring yes I
was two-time European champion two-time
2008-2009 wka Federation till 76 kilos I
think it's a welterweight now category
and 2013 I want the belt in australia
melbourne i kbf world champion 76 kilos
when I figure out that it's there is a
little little problem when I start
practicing Islam I figure out that is
forbidden to kick and punch it in the
face and I start stopped with the
competition my last fight was
before four years 2014 in October 2014
against one guys from New Zealand and
maybe I will continue in competition
after four and a half years in the July
in Sarajevo will be Kaka King of Kings
one event maybe I will fight a fight
about that event because I have to
continue my PhD this is a real reason
because I back in the ring you remind me
of a good friend of mine a leek aitikaf
if you've heard of him he was a
professional fighter for 15 years he's
from the from Russia from Russia from
yeah from the caucus mountains there
what's up Valley how you doing brother
where bothered you I'm so lost my league
amazing brother he gave up actually just
like you he gave up fighting and he's
you know because of the Dean you know
but tell us when people see us now when
they see you
young brother coming out of the Masjid
you know to me a lot of the youth
they're going gone away from prayer what
attracted you to Islam that had you
actually now living it in your life for
the past how many years I I start with
with practicing Islam with maybe seven
years ago
and III have to say that one guy from
internet I I think you know I think that
every Muslim no for that guy
dr. zakir naik when i heard and saw this
video and i figure out that faith but
that islam it's a most important thing
in the world of one a human being and my
my life i changed my life all my life
when i when i figured when I heard as I
can I can figure out that it's Aslam is
most important thinking what advice do
you have for for people in general to
really take the matter seriously to to
think about those most important
questions of life why are we here what's
the purpose of life what do you like to
get them to thinking beyond the
materialism beyond just you know the
touch and feel you know really take
things serious like you did only if
human being figure out that why we live
in in this world all this ass fur have
match you can from you can find yes you
can find in Islam Islam
right gives you all those answers yes
all answers why we leave
finally we why Allah create us I think
that this is more most important thing
even in the life of one one human being
that's beautiful I mean you have all the
answers for all the questions in life
you'll find it in Iran in Quran and
hadith of Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind when you accept him you accept
all the preceding messengers Jesus Moses
Abraham because they all came with the
same message Islam to submit your will
to the Creator not the crazy and somehow
they connected us to being family huh
yes maybe maybe we talk we we talked
before the pre migrant migrant grandpa
her surname is rich like you maybe you
and I amazing so I met some family my
brother does Alcala Haider and will seek
here inside our peace Salam alaikum
Salam